[موسيقى]
عبد الوهاب انا صورته صورت معه عبد الحليم
حافظ اجعل عمان
وصورته
فريد الاطرش صباح الصوره لما كنا ناخذها
كنا ناخدها نحط قطع على العاده
تطلع الصوره
لمده ثواني وترجعها على اساس المناسب
اللي انت حار
[موسيقى]
محمد اكرم الطويل اقدم مصور في عمان
المؤسسه تبعتنا يعني افتتحناها او بلشنا
نشتغل فيها
سنه 1954
لغايه الان والحمد لله احنا موافقين طبعا
مواكبين كل شيء جديد
كنا نشتغل بايدينا محمد
صور محمد اصبع وجه اضاءه شغله التصوير
شغله فن ما كان في لا عنا ماكينات ولا كان
يعني كنا مركنين بس على الايد العامله
اليد العامله اللي هي اصحاب المهنه
[موسيقى]
الصوره لما كنا ناخذها كنا ناخذها نحط
قطعه على العدسه ما كان في شهر
وتجلس عليه تطلع الصوره
المناسب هو القمر استخدمتها هي هذه
الثمانيه
مش ممكن يعني انه تنجح اي انسان
ممكن يصور فيه بالنسبه للتصوير الاصلي
الفني اللي همم المعتبر انه مهنه المهنه
مش همم خذ
الكاميرا ويصور فيها الاصل
من موبايل او بالكاميرات الديجيتال بين
قدامك لكن بالنسبه للتصوير
الفوتوغرافي العادي الاصلي اللي هو المهنه
ثلاث مراحل
التصوير توزيع الاضاءه التحميل
اول شيء
انا عندي هوايه وفي نفس الوقت محبه
[موسيقى]
والله يا عم شخصيه صورته وجلاله الملك
الحسين الله يرحمه ويحسن اليه
بمناسبات عديده عبد الوهاب انا صورته
صورته عبد الحليم حافظ اجعل عمان
فريد الاطرش صباح
[موسيقى]
ي انا بحب الصوره
واذا بدك تيجي تفتش عندي بتلاقي لك 15 20
الف صوره
من جميع الطبقات
امانه لا انا بحب الصور القديمه
[موسيقى]